Lý độ là Vì Gí của bạn ở thời gian tầy.
Nếu bạn ở bị gí để mẹ ngờ thì Lý độ của bạn bằng bốn sẵn tìm em.
Tố như là vật năng ở bị gí, các bị gí bằng bằng ổ bổ sẵn tìm em.
Và vật năng ở nguyện vương của chục và lộ.
Khi vật năng ở bị gí tại nhiều em lợ, vật có một lý độ et bằng tâm hài xình thì mẹ.
Bốn như là gì? Bốn như là vật hát bị gí cân bằng ổ hài xình thì mẹ như vật năng ở bị gí miền ẵn tục và lộ.
Và ở bị gí lợ á một khi bật sẽ có lý độ et bằng,
cho sâu xình thì mẹ.
Bốn như là vật hữu bị gí cân bằng ổ xâu xình thì mẹ như vật hữu.
Vật hữu bị gí miền ẵn tục và lộ.
Lý độ là Vì gí của bạn,
đàn một thời rừng, đánh nào đó trong quá trịnh vật sau đó.
Lý độ của thế giới, của thế giới, của thế giới, của thế giới.
Đừng giả, đừng giả, đừng giả, đừng giả.